[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER CROSBIE:
I spend a lot
of my time building security
features in Cloud Dataproc,
which is, if you're
not familiar,
our managed Hadoop and Spark
offering on Google Cloud.
Joining with me
today is Larry McCay.
He is from Cloudera.
He's got over 20 years of
overall security experience,
including seven in
Hadoop security.
And he's currently the PMC chair
of Apache Knox, a system that
provides a single point of
authentication and access
for Apache Hadoop services.
Also with me is Julien
Phalip, Solutions Architect
at Google Cloud.
And we're going to chat today
about securing your data lake,
specifically around securing
your data lakes that
are based around the Hadoop
platform and Hadoop ecosystem.
So I'm finding
three main reasons
why customers are building
data lakes on Google Cloud.
First of all, there's
just a lot of new sources
of data coming in from a
variety of places, streaming
applications, IoT, device data.
And that just means there's
a lot more unstructured data
around that you have to
deal with, secure, analyze.
The second reason is that folks
are building data lakes on GCP
is that just data is becoming
a lot more self-service now.
IT departments,
they're getting away
from this idea of having a
centralized reporting team.
And I think there's a
lot of reasons for that.
But the primary one is
simply that data now
is just becoming
way too important
to wait on all
the inefficiencies
that are typically imposed
by teams like that.
Also the tools for
working with data,
they're becoming a lot
more mainstream and easier
to work with.
So you're also
finding business users
are a lot more data savvy.
And the third reason is
that users now need access
to a lot more data
than they used to,
a lot more ranges of data.
At the same time, businesses
are getting a lot more stringent
privacy regulations.
And they want to protect
their PII trade secrets.
And so companies,
they need to start
automating a lot of those
privacy checks and data access
because you just
can't keep up with all
of the different sources.
Most of the talks focused
today that we're about to do
is on this third reason.
But we also find that to
satisfy the first two reasons,
oftentimes, this
is a requirement,
to help with number one and two.
So customers are using
Google Cloud Platform
to build data lakes
because we have
a lot of those tools that are
commonly found in data lakes.
So whether it's data
ingestion, data processing,
data management,
or data security,
GCP probably has an
option for your use case.
Now I can't even begin to
scratch the surface of all
the different offerings
that you see on this slide,
in this talk.
But what I am going
to try to do is
I'm going to try to answer for
why security-minded customers,
like yourself, are choosing
GCP to secure their data lakes.
So the GCP platform,
as a whole, we
have independent verification
of our security, privacy,
and compliance controls.
Google undergoes independent
third-party audits
on a regular basis to
provide this assurance.
So this means that an
independent auditor has come in
and examined all of our controls
and all of our data centers
in our infrastructure
and in our operations.
And so the
certifications that we
tend to go after, these are
going to be the most widely
recognized, independent,
and widely accepted
security standards.
So you're going to find things
like ISO for our security
controls, and cloud
security, and privacy.
But then we also-- you're
going to find things
like our SOC 1, 2, and 3.
And all of these certifications,
having these in place,
what this really helps us do
is meet industry standards
like PCI, or like HIPAA.
And we're going to continue
to expand the list that you
see here with
certifications globally
to make sure that we can
help our customers meet
their compliance obligations.
Now another reason why
security-minded customers
choose GCP is because we have
deep and wide features that
make it easy to keep
your data secure.
So we have default
at-rest encryption.
If anyone here has ever had
to deal with doing like a LUKS
encryption on drives,
you know the pain
both from a performance and
management perspective--
like aspects of doing that.
And so Google Cloud, anytime we
land data, it gets encrypted.
And that just makes it easy.
But at the same time, you
can often control the keys.
So if you want to have
customer-managed encryption
keys for that data that's
stored, you can do that.
You can rotate those
keys on your schedule,
revoke those keys
as you need to.
Most of our products also
integrate with Stackdriver.
That's going to offer you
a single pane of glass
for your data access and audit
logs across all the Cloud
products and even other clouds.
Stackdriver can integrate
with other clouds as well.
We also have OS Login.
If you're not familiar
with that feature, that
lets you take a
Cloud IAM Identity,
translate that
into a Linux user,
and the big benefit
there is that you
don't have to be handing out
and managing SSH keys to get
into your virtual machines.
We also have VPC
Service Controls
which is going to
give you the ability
to do a lot of the
things that you're
doing in your on-prem networking
stack in Google Cloud.
And then we also have Cloud
Identity and Access Management
as well as Kerberos
support in Dataproc.
And I'm going to talk
a little bit more
about those in a minute.
But before I do, I want to come
back to some of the data lake
commonalities that I'm seeing.
So I think between
the three of us,
I think we've seen countless
data lake implementations
from a variety of industries.
And at least me,
personally, I don't
think I've ever seen
two that were alike.
Have you guys ever seen
two customer data lakes
that were exactly alike?
No.
But there are three
common elements
that every data lake
has got to address,
ingestion, storage, and
then a compute platform
that's going to let you use
a variety of tools to mine
and identify workflows.
So from my perspective,
at least, ingest,
that tends to be
all over the place.
Data is now coming in
from just everywhere,
all sorts of volumes,
all sorts of velocities.
And even like in
my GCP world, I've
seen a lot of common tools,
but a universal pattern
I've not seen for ingest yet.
However, when it comes
to number 2 and number 3
where you store
the data and then
having a platform
for tools, customers
do tend to answer
these in the same way.
So in Cloud Storage, at
least in Google Cloud,
is the store for the data lake.
It's the hub that brings
together GCP around your data.
It's going to check that
box for most of those
features that a
data lake storage
system is going to require.
You're going to have
high durability,
centralized security
controls, storage classes that
help you optimize cost.
And one very relevant
for Hadoop and Spark
is we have immediate
consistency.
Now that's a really
important feature
that allows you to
use Cloud Storage
as a drop-in
replacement for HDFS
without adding a
bunch of workarounds,
like NoSQL databases.
And so once customers
land on Cloud Storage
and they've identified that
as their storage mechanism,
the next step is
typically trying
to identify a way to manage
and mine and identify
all those various workflows.
More often than not,
customers always
choose a platform over
a specific tool that
lets them run a variety
of open-source processing
applications.
You really need a platform
that can provide lots
of and the latest capabilities.
So Cloudera and Cloud Dataproc
both provide these platforms.
Cloudera is focused on building
a unified, hybrid cloud.
Where Cloud Dataproc, we tend
to want to modernize your stack
and pull you into the
Google Cloud Platform.
Yet because both
of us are working
on so many of the
similar capabilities
and in the
open-source community,
we were able to come together
and build some common security
infrastructure that
we both could use.
So in a bit, Larry
and Julien are
going to talk a little bit
more about that collaboration.
But before I hand
off to them, I want
to leave you with some IAM
best practices for data lakes.
So just to backup and
just baseline Cloud IAM,
it is who can do what
on which resources.
So you're typically going
to have a project owner.
They'll invite
members to projects.
Then they're going
to grant them roles.
And then those
roles, those consist
of a collection of permissions
for one or more resources.
Some basic IAM
best practices, you
want to definitely follow the
principle of least privilege.
That applies to identities,
roles, and resources.
So you always want to
select the smallest
scope necessary to reduce
your exposure to risk.
So you're not going
to grow and grant
everybody like an owner role
to your entire organization.
There's intentional
hacks or mistakes, that
could bring down applications.
You want to be really
specific and deliberate
and assign a specific group,
like a security admin role,
to manage SSL certs and
firewalls on specific projects.
And you want to use groups
as much as possible.
So dealing with
managing permissions
for individual users, that
can be really cumbersome.
It can be error-prone.
So you want to use groups.
You can see in this
example, we have
users that are getting added
to a SecOps team group.
And then it's that group that's
going to get your permissions,
like security admin
and log viewer.
You also want to make sure
that you have policies in place
to secure your resources.
You want to make sure
you're controlling
how additional users gain access
to resources through policies
and group memberships.
Because without strict
control over those policies,
you might be inadvertently
allowing new users
more permission than they need.
And then now we're
back to violating
that principle of least policy.
OK.
At this point, maybe a lot
of you are rolling your eyes
or pulling out your phones
thinking, yeah, Chris,
I get this.
This is every RBAC system ever.
And there's some
validity to that.
But here's some
important things to keep
in mind that are actually
different in Google Cloud.
So you're going to have two
members of your data lake
in Google Cloud.
You're going to have
the accounts that
might be either a Gmail
or a Google address.
Most likely, you're going
to have folks coming
from your G Suite domain.
So that's going to be the
folks that have an @ and then
your company's name dot com.
It's important to understand
that GCP does not create
or manage users or groups.
I'm going to say
that one more time.
GCP does not create or
manage users or groups.
So the "I" in our IAM, that's
almost a bit of a misnomer
sometimes.
When you assign a permission
to someone in Cloud IAM,
it's going onto that user.
But that user lives
outside of the GCP project.
And they might be associated
with many GCP projects or even
a different organization
altogether with a different set
of permissions.
That's why in GCP
in your data lake,
it is really important
to scope things
as much as possible
with service accounts
because those service accounts
are associated and limited
to those GCP projects.
So now that we understand
that users and groups are not
part of your specific
GCP projects,
here are some data
lake best practices
that may not be quite as
intuitive as that first set.
So your data lake objects,
your GCS bucket ACLs,
those default ACLs, any object
ACLs as much as possible,
those should contain groups.
Great.
We established that.
But those groups,
as much as possible,
should contain IAM
service accounts.
You want those service
accounts, then,
to represent a type
of automated workload.
And then what you're
going to want to do
is grant end users the
iam.serviceAccountUser role
to that service account.
You also, as much as
possible, the goal
here is we want
to avoid exposing
a long-live credential.
Really avoid that if that
credential is associated
with a real end user
because remember, that user,
they might have other
permissions that are not
part of your GCP project.
So let's say I'm
working with Larry.
And he's from Cloudera.
He only has some read-only, the
identified access to my data.
I might think, whatever.
I'll give him a
long-lived credential
because it doesn't really
matter in my project.
But if it is with his real
user, he also probably
has access to potentially other
Cloudera-- in other Cloudera
area projects, he
could be an admin.
And so creating these
long-lived credentials
for real people, that creates
almost like a somewhat
ambiguous blast radius,
because you're not just limited
to the GCP projects
that you have
control over for these users.
And so also as much as
possible, try to use
the Google APIs,
things like the GCloud,
or if you're using
Cloud Dataproc,
use the Jobs API to break apart
isolation and permissions.
So the Cloud Dataproc
Jobs API, that
will determine who
can submit jobs
to the cluster versus who has
actual access to the cluster.
And better yet is even
if you can do isolation
based on the VM or
the cluster itself.
And so I know I just said
that's my best practice,
is isolate by VM or cluster.
But I'm also very well
aware that that is not
practical in reality for
a lot of situations, which
is exactly why we do have
a beta version of Kerberos
now integrated with Dataproc.
And this is going
to let you do things
like tie back your Dataproc
users to Active Directory.
It also makes it as
simple as a button click
to turn on security features
like Hadoop secure mode
or encryption in-flight.
Now, the standard model
in this Kerberos beta
is that users access
Cloud Dataproc.
They're going to obtain a
Kerberos principal for the work
that they do on
the cluster itself.
And then everything done on the
cluster is that Kerberos user.
However, if the data does need
to get accessed from the data
lake in Google Cloud
Storage, that data
is going to get obtained
using the service account
credentials of the virtual
machines of the cluster.
Now, this model
works really well
for customers that can lock down
their Cloud Storage buckets.
And this is really what
a lot of customers want.
They want all the security
controls in their cluster.
That lets them use tools
like Apache Ranger.
However, we do have
a lot of customers
with very stringent security
and compliance requirements
that actually need to translate
that identity, that Kerberos
identity back into a Cloud
identity so the chain of access
never gets broken.
This is actually
a security problem
that exists across other
cloud providers as well.
And it was something
that Google and Cloudera
were both working to address.
And so I think you now
know where this is headed.
I'm going to hand
off to Larry now
to talk about how Google
and Cloudera came together
to solve that dilemma.
LARRY MCCAY: OK.
What Chris was
talking about just now
is something that I've been
calling the cloud identity
crisis.
And we'll dig into
what that means.
So challenges for
data lake identity
when we're in the cloud or we're
accessing cloud data, something
I call the identity gap.
We'll get into each
of these things.
Related to this, we end
up with a phenomenon
called credential
sprawl and also
this issue of being able to use
short-lived credentials rather
than long-lived credentials.
So this gray area on this slide
represents this identity gap.
And on one side, you have
the Hadoop and Kerberos
users or your Enterprise users
which Hadoop knows about.
And the other side, you have
your client Cloud IAM users
and identities, which
Cloud Storage knows about.
But Cloud Storage doesn't
know about Kerberos users.
And Hadoop doesn't
know about IAM users.
So we've actually supported
these cloud data connectors
for a number of years.
And we've had to
bridge this gap.
So these don't really
represent points in time.
But these are
different approaches
that have been used to
try to bridge this gap.
And they're all some flavor
of Bring Your Own Keys.
So we started out using
environment variables.
We've had username and
password in the URL
itself to have your keys.
We have configuration
files where
you put your keys in there.
We have instance profile
or service accounts
associated with the VM,
which Chris mentioned.
We added the ability to protect
your keys with the Hadoop
CredentialProvider.
And coming soon, we have a
delegation token support.
So these are all attempts
to kind of bridge that gap.
But they led to this
credential sprawl.
So I have many jobs
from many users running.
And they're
configuring your keys
across your platform
in various ways.
How do you know where they are?
How do you know
where they end up?
They are in-- possibly
in environment variables.
Not often anymore, but could be.
Configuration files.
They could be in
credential stores,
which are key stores that are
across your data platform.
They could end up in process
listings in log files.
They could end up in
GitHub repositories.
So this is what I'm
calling credential sprawl.
It's hard to find them.
It's hard to clean them up.
And it's very easy to leak them.
So we need a way
to address that.
If you notice, I'm not saying
anything about number 5
here yet.
This is related to the work
that we've come together
to work on and collaborate on.
And this introduces the use
of delegation tokens, which
is a native part of Hadoop.
And this is the standard
way that credentials
are propagated across
your data platform for use
by worker tasks that
don't have Kerberos
credentials of their own
possibly and things like that.
They are securely
distributed with the jobs
and cleaned up when
the jobs are done.
They're also time-constrained
with an expiration time
and a fixed number of times
that they could be renewed
within another time period.
And very importantly,
they're already
supported in the
existing Hadoop clients.
So in order to introduce a
new delegation token type
or to introduce new sources
of delegation tokens,
you don't have to change
any of the Hadoop clients.
So this can also be leveraged
to broker tokens, which
we'll talk about later.
So this picture--
I'm not going to talk
in great detail about this
because Julien actually
has a nice presentation
of this overall flow.
But this is the
canonical picture
of how delegation
tokens are actually
used for accessing HDFS.
So a user logs in,
and they submit a job.
The Hadoop client
interrogates the file systems
that are being
used and tells them
to go collect their
delegation tokens, which
then get distributed
to the worker nodes
and are available to those
tasks while they're running.
And upon job completion,
they're all cleaned up.
So that's essentially
Kerberos for HDFS.
Remember that.
So open source, open source is
actually why I'm on the stage
here.
It's actually why I
joined Hortonworks
when I joined
Hortonworks and why
I'm happy to still be
with the new Cloudera
to work in open source.
So contributors to open source
not only dedicate their time
and commit their time
to these projects,
but at the end of the day,
they put their name on it.
So I want to call
out some people who
have worked on this stuff
because this is moving
the platform forward actually.
So Steve Loughran, who
happens to work for Cloudera,
created this GRN,
this patch, which
added delegation token
support to S3A, which is
a data connector for S3 access.
He also provided an out
of the box implementation
for those delegation tokens to
limit that credential sprawl.
So you can now use your
keys from your desktop only,
so authenticate the
AWS, and submit a job.
And his change, we'll
call AWS STS service,
and acquire a short-lived
session tokens where you.
And they get distributed as
delegation tokens with the jobs
and cleaned up when
the job's complete.
They are short-lived tokens.
And there's no really
way to renew them.
But it really minimizes this
credential sprawl phenomenon
to your desktop where
you're using them.
So this was a
great step forward.
So as we looked
at that mechanism
and we realized
with minimal change,
we can swap out the
source of these tokens,
we realized we can
start normalizing
how tokens are accessed
across all of the cloud vendor
connectors.
So Phil Zampino,
also from Cloudera,
contributed a patch
back to the GCS data
connector in open source.
And Julien, Igor, and Chao
reviewed and collaborated
and improved this
patch so that it
works as well as the S3A patch
did and meets the same needs.
So that brings me to the
Cloudera Identity Broker
And this is an upcoming feature.
It is not released yet.
The goals, essentially,
if we were to boil
it down is remember, I
say, Kerberos for HDFS.
This is Kerberos for the cloud.
It's the easiest
way to think of it.
You log in with your
Enterprise credentials
and KN it as normally.
Delegation tokens are
acquired from the IDBroker
and then later used to acquire
access tokens as needed.
The goals for the
IDBroker itself
are a secure multi-user data
lake deployment in the cloud.
And its multicloud
and hybrid cloud.
Like I said, you authenticate
with your Enterprise
credentials.
We only use
short-term IAM tokens.
And we leverage your
existing investment
in Cloud IAM policies
and tooling, et cetera.
We also have the ability to
renew those short-term tokens.
So long-lived jobs will
still maintain their access.
So this is a simple picture of
the existing ecosystem of data
connectors along with HDFS.
And these red credentials needed
represents that identity gap
we were talking about before.
And all those many ways of
filling that gap were used.
But this is the picture
we're moving towards now.
So all the existing
clients are going
to be talking to
the data connectors
and telling them to go get their
delegation tokens transparently
to the user.
They're getting acquired
from the identity broker.
And access tokens are
acquired and ready for access
to Cloud Storage.
So this is essentially
Kerberos for the Cloud.
The same picture is
Kerberos for HDFS.
But it shows how
the Identity Broker
is used for acquiring delegation
tokens and access tokens
and then subsequently
providing access
to Cloud Storage from
the worker nodes.
So in order for us to have--
and one of our
requirements was actually
to not require IAM users for
every one of your Enterprise
users.
In order to not do that, we
need a way to associate "roles"
quote unquote.
In S3, they are
actually IAM roles.
In GCP, they are
service accounts.
So we associate group
memberships to roles.
And we have a role
selection algorithm
that picks the best match
based on configuration
based on these
mappings and based
on a number of other things.
And this is just
a mockup of what
a UI will look like to do this.
So kind of just to
illustrate the power of this,
of being able to just use
your Enterprise credentials,
we'll walk through
a simple use case
of migrating data from one cloud
provider to another using TCP.
So you log in with your
typical Kerberos kinit.
And you issue the
Hadoop distcp command
with your source and
your destination URLs.
And you can see by
the scheme there
that one is for S3 and
one is for Google Storage.
So the client, as
I described before,
iterates over the file
systems it's about to use
and tells it to collect
its delegation tokens.
The delegation tokens are then
collected from the IDBroker
for both of those file systems.
They're collected into
the App Launch Context.
And you can see one for each
of the cloud storage vendors
there as well as in HDFS,
the delegation token here.
And YARN, it
distributes it along
with the App Launch
Context and the credentials
in a secure manner.
And during execution,
those credentials
are used to move the data
from the source bucket
to the destination bucket.
And the way that it does that
is it takes the delegation token
and it authenticates
the IDBroker.
Even though it doesn't
have Kerberos credentials,
it's using that
delegation token.
And it's requesting
access tokens.
It will also ask for new
access tokens when they expire.
And then as the job
completes, delegation tokens
are all cleaned up.
And we eliminate credential
sprawl completely.
We logged in with our
Enterprise credentials.
And we ended up dynamically
getting access tokens
for as long as we needed, even
though they're short-lived,
from multiple cloud vendors.
And your data is now migrated.
So just kind of a
summary slide here.
We have multicloud access token
acquisition for AWS, S3, Google
GCS.
Azure ADLS Gen2 is
still being worked on.
You only need your Enterprise
credentials as I said.
Supports long-lived jobs
with short-lived tokens
and leverages the existing
support in Hadoop clients.
Another thing to
be aware of, which
is a related but
separate effort,
is that we are working on
common Enterprise data policy
across on-prem and Cloud
Storage data access.
So that's also coming soon.
So I will hand it
over now to Julien
who will talk about the GCP
Token Broker, which was enabled
by the same collaboration.
JULIEN PHALIP: Thank you, Larry.
And hi, everyone.
I'm Julien Phalip.
I'm a solutions architect
at Google Cloud.
And I'm really excited
to introduce you
to the GCP Token Broker.
So what is the GCP Token Broker?
It is a brand new
open-source project
that we just released last week.
It currently is in alpha.
And I will talk
to you a bit more
about the upcoming roadmap.
So this is the result
of a close collaboration
that we've had with several
large Hadoop customers
as well as with partners such
as Cloudera and Hortonworks.
The project on GitHub
contains documentation
about the design
that we've aligned on
as well as reference
implementation.
So this project is intended
for Enterprise customers
who are currently using
Kerberos to secure
their on-prem clusters
and who are looking
to migrate those
clusters to the Cloud
and try to replicate the same
user workflows and experience.
So this is particularly
valuable for customers
who are interested in a hybrid
environment where they can
let the users run jobs
on-prem as well as run jobs
in the Cloud.
So the main goal for
the GCP Token Broker
is to ease that migration.
And this is done by leveraging
the same Kerberos and Hadoop
delegation token facility
that Larry introduced to.
This facility allows
to securely distribute
short-lived credentials
across a cluster.
It also allows for a
seamless integration
across multiple
tools and frameworks
around the Hadoop ecosystem.
That includes things like
Spark, Hive, Tez, YARN,
MapReduce, and many others.
And because the
integration is so seamless,
this reduces the
changes that you
have to make when you're
migrating your clusters.
The Broker also helps
enforce AAA security.
This means that users
can continue to use
Kerberos to authenticate.
And you can also have a
very granular authorization
where you can set permission
on individual users
for specific buckets.
And as far as
accounting goes, these
are also allows you to do
some very granular access
logs, which is very useful for
troubleshooting, monitoring,
or detailed chargebacks where
you can trace back which user
actually used which
bucket or which resources
in the Cloud at what time.
And the Broker offers
tight integration
with the Google Cloud
Services, starting
with Cloud Storage in the
future with other services,
such as BigQuery or Bigtable.
So while the IDBroker
that Larry talked to
is focused on the
Cloudera environment
and to allow
multicloud jobs to run,
the Broker currently is
focused on the Google Cloud
environment.
Now looking at the
workflow at a high level,
again, this should
look familiar.
It's trying to solve
the same problem
that Larry described earlier.
So you have your users,
your Kerberos principals,
who want to use a Hadoop
environment to run jobs.
And as part of those
jobs, they want
to also be able to access Cloud
resources like Cloud Storage.
Now, Cloud Storage, like
all the Cloud services,
work with Cloud Identities.
So what do you want
to achieve basically
is you want to let your users
to continue using Kerberos
to authenticate and
run jobs and some way,
somehow match those identities
with Cloud Identities
so that they can then
access Cloud services.
Now let's zoom in a little
bit in that Hadoop environment
to see how it all works.
So now the system revolves
around this Broker service.
There is a prerequisite
that you need
to set up first, that is to use
Google Cloud Directory Sync.
It's a tool that's been
around for a long time.
What it does it will sync your
LDAP on-prem identities over
to Cloud Identities.
This is done automatically.
It will sync all of
your users and groups.
Once you have all of your
identities synced in the Cloud,
you can then write standard
IAM policies for those users
and groups and dictate what
those users and groups are
allowed to access.
In a Hadoop context,
typically, this
would mean setting
permissions on GCS buckets.
And then once that's
in place, your users
are ready to submit jobs.
So here is Alice, a
Kerberos principal.
What Alice will do
first is to log in
by running the kinit
command with the KDC.
The KDC is backed by
your LDAP database.
And also, very
importantly, the Broker
is also connected
to the same KDC
so that it will be able to
authenticate your users further
along in the process.
Then now that
Alice is logged in,
she can submit a job by
using a Hadoop client.
First thing that
the client does is
to contact the broker to ask
for new delegation token.
The Broker at this
point uses Kerberos
to authenticate
the user, make sure
that that user is
who they claim to be
and then generates a new
access token and return that--
sorry, a delegation token and
return the delegation token
to the client.
The client then submits a job
to the YARN Resource Manager
and passes along that
delegation token.
The YARN Resource Manager,
the first thing that he does
is to send a renew
request to the Broker just
to make sure that it has full
authority over that delegation
token.
And then the job is effectively
submitted across a cluster
over multiple tasks.
As those tasks are running
at some point in time,
they might need to access Cloud
Storage, whether to read a file
or write a file.
When a task needs to do that,
the first thing that it will do
is to contact the
Broker again, this time
by pulling the delegation
token from the secure context
and sending the dedication
token to the Broker.
The Broker then verifies that
the delegation token is still
valid.
And if so will then call the
Google OAuth API to generate
a new access token
for the Cloud Identity
that maps to the
Kerberos identity.
That access token is then
returned over to the task.
And a task can then access Cloud
Storage as that Cloud Identity,
so Alice, the Cloud Identity.
And then at the end,
when, the job is complete
the YARN Resource Manager will
call the Broker one last time
and call the cancel on point.
This will effectively make the
delegation token inoperable
so that it cannot be reused
outside of the context of this
job.
So from the very
beginning, the Token Broker
was designed with
scalability in mind
by using several fully managed
products on Google Cloud.
That includes Kubernetes
Engine, Cloud Datastore,
Cloud Memorystore, Cloud KMS.
Now let's look at how
this all fits together.
What you can see here
in the top-left corner
is the Broker environment.
The Broker service is
running on Kubernetes Engine.
And then you can
scale that cluster
up to how ever many nodes as
you need to bear the load that's
required for your users.
The state is stored in a
database on Cloud Datastore,
which is a highly
scalable NoSQL database
and fully managed
on Google Cloud.
That state includes the
delegation token and also
some session details that
are attached to the jobs that
are currently running.
There is a cache currently
using Redis on Cloud Memorystore
to improve performance.
Cloud KMS is used to
encrypt any sensitive data.
So for example, before
caching the access token,
those tokens are
encrypted with KMS.
And every operation
done by the Broker
is also logged in Stackdriver.
So you can monitor how
the Broker is used.
Now looking at the
top-right corner,
this is your client environment.
This is where your Hadoop
clusters will be running.
And you can choose to run
it either as a self-managed
cluster on Compute Engine.
Or you can also
use Dataproc, which
is Google's fully managed
Hadoop and Spark service.
A couple of configuration
setup that you have to do,
first, you need to
set up a two-way trust
between the client machines
and the Broker service.
This is to allow
services like YARN that
are running on the current
machines to access the Broker
and also to allow
logged in Kerberos users
to also access the Broker.
And then you also need
to set up a one-way trust
between the Broker
and the LDAP database.
This is so that the Broker
can authenticate your users.
And then you can
have your data be
hosted on any number
of buckets as you need.
What you can see here with the
dotted lines are separate VPCs.
All of those VPCs
are private VPCs.
All of those machines
only use private IPs.
And you can then interconnect
those VPCs in different ways,
by using VPC sharing,
VPC peering, or VPNs.
So this, I want to emphasize
is only an example deployment.
The project on Github
contains Terraform scripts
that will allow you to
automatically deploy
this architecture.
But you should just use
that as a starting point
and adapt it potentially to
your production environment
as you see fit.
And then you can also swap
out any of those components.
So if you choose to
use, for example, MySQL,
a MySQL database
to store the state,
you can totally do that and
replace Datastore, for example.
Or you can also use
Memcached instead of Redis.
Quick word on the road map.
So this current FR
release contains support
for Cloud Storage
and also supports
Kerberos as the authentication
backend and also supports
proxy users, which is a Hadoop
concept that allows services
like Hive, for example, to
impersonate other users.
In the upcoming
beta, we're going
to focus on performance
optimizations
and on stabilizing the API.
And then if-- sorry,
in future releases,
we will add several more
features most prominently
by adding support for
BigQuery and Bigtable.
So I invite you to look
at the project on Github
for more details about
the design, the roadmap,
as well as the actual
implementation that you
can then try out and
use in your environment.
We would really appreciate
a good feedback.
We want to make sure that we
can implement all the features
that you want and need.
So please feel
free to try it out.
And get in touch with
your sales team at Google.
And then we'll be sure to
follow up and make sure
that we iterate and
make it better for you.
So yeah, thank you very much.
This is the end of the talk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]